[російською] Все гаразд.
[російською] Все гаразд, так!
[російською] Ходив довкола, їв.
[російською] Все гаразд, так. Злякався?
[російською] Це козли, моя любов!
[сміється]
[російською] Обожнюю всіх своїх козлів.
[російською] Все, нічого страшного вже, стій!
Зараз я тебе заберу.
[російською] Зараз Юра тебе забере, зараз.
[російською] Чи ти хочеш, щоб я тебе почухала?
[російською] Ми займалися тренінгами, вчили людей,
[російською] що кожен громадянин України
має право отримати два гектари землі
[російською] для ведення
особистого селянського господарства.
[російською] Ну і, знаєте, як швець без чобіт:
що ж це ми усіх вчимо, що всі мають право.
[російською] Всі кажуть: «Не віримо, доведіть».
Ми вирішили довести.
[російською] І ми отримали на себе, на дітей, на батьків.
[російською] Тут були зарості, джунглі,
неможливо було пройти взагалі.
[російською] На той момент ми вже років 15
займалися рекламним бізнесом.
[російською] Своє агентство в нас уже було.
[російською] І Таня каже:
«Давай десь купимо 20 кіз. Спробуємо».
[російською] Я кажу:
«А що ми на 20 козах спробуємо? Давай хоча б 100!».
Коза-коза-коза-коза!
[російською] Ми коли сюди переїхали,
у нас на руках була дитина, якій один рік і п'ять місяців.
[російською] Нам дозволили вивезти весь наш товар
з магазину, у нас було два магазини в Ялті.
[російською] Я був учасником Майдану з першого
до останнього дня, тому їхати довелося дуже швидко.
[російською] В Армянську на блокпосту ми вже проривались,
нормально влетіли на наш бік, нас не наздогнали.
[російською] Приїхали сюди,
це будинок діда, купили ферму.
Спершу батьки мої переїхали в 2010 році.
А ми з дружиною приєдналися в 2014 [році].
І вже тоді зародилася ідея «Лісової ферми».
Мої дідусь і бабуся тут живуть, тобто точно
чотири покоління тому всі наші тут жили.
Я навчався в [Сполучених] Штатах,
чотири роки працював у бізнесі.
Коли я в місті перебував, то мені було тяжко.
Алергії були, все...
А коли сюди приїжджав, все як рукою знімало!
Але вже з часом, те, що ми почали тут робити, я зрозумів,
що для мене це не просто якийсь дауншифтинг.
По суті, ми тут такий мікро- чи міні-бізнес будуємо.
Це колосальний досвід.
Зараз у нас тут охолоджується молоко,
з якого ми будемо сьогодні робити сир.
Для того, щоб зробити сир,
молоко спочатку треба пропастеризувати,
тобто нагріти до температури, вищої за 62 градуси.
Ну і витримати його потім при цій температурі 30 хвилин.
Почалось все з двох кіз.
На меті не було виробництва сиру спочатку,
а просто продаж молока.
Зараз доїться в нас 180 кіз
і [є] десь більше двох десятків козенят.
На цьому столику ми будемо формувати сир,
тобто розкладати сирне зерно по формах.
Сформувався згусток, який можна вже розрізати,
і ми почнемо бачити народження сиру на перших стадіях.
[російською] Ось таке зерно сирне,
[російською] з якого потім виходить щільний згусток
і наші улюблені козячі сири.
[російською] Ось виходить десь
зо 25-30 літрів сироватки і [один] кілограм рікоти.
[російською] Ось робимо моцарелу.
[російською] Тут ми бачимо і традиційні
козячі сири з білою пліснявою: камамбер і шевр.
[російською] І такі інноваційні на сьогодні,
як белпер кноль з перцем і часником,
[російською] біла пліснява, тверді сири...
А це тут камера, в якій визрівають сири.
А це дошка...
Це цьому сиру десь близько двох місяців, мабуть.
Цим сирам, що ось на цих трьох поличках,
вже більше року, вони зроблені в травні минулого року.
Тобто їм уже фактично один рік і один місяць.
Вони за консистенцією вже схожі на пармезан, сухі.
Виробляємо близько 12 видів мила з козиного масла.
Оскільки воно робиться холодним способом, то,
як і для сиру, йому треба час для того, щоб визріти.
Визріває таке мило близько одного місяця
так само на дерев'яних дошках.
Це все натуральні компоненти тут.
Ну от, наприклад, кавове мило — туди додано мелену каву.
В асортименті є тільки два види сиру.
Це козиний — тут можна бачити, вони менші головки.
І коров'ячий — більші головки.
Знову ж таки, натуральні закваски,
молоко, сіль, фермент.
Нічого більше не додається.
Козюлі!
Козюльки!
[російською] Хто буде їсти?
[російською] Ми починали — це просто було аматорське,
[російською] побачити, що це за бізнес, почавши з 10-15 кіз.
[російською] Я навчилась доїти, приймати пологи у кіз.
[російською] Вісім місяців тому ми ще навіть не уявляли,
що таке сир, як він робиться, як утримувати кіз.
[російською] Це взагалі, я ніколи не думав,
що це настільки важко.
[російською] Тут, скоріш за все, у нас трійня, як мінімум.
[російською] Ось уже останні дні.
— [російською] Тихо, тихо!
— [російською] Йди сюди! Що ти мало так приніс?
[російською] Але пальці в рота їй краще не класти,
якщо вона сухарі так гризе  і кору з дерев згризає.
[російською] Козівництво стало престижним.
[російською] Коли ми починали, багато хто сміявся.
[російською] Наприклад, коли говорили, що хочемо завести кіз,
[російською] ходили в митну службу, в управління:
[російською] «Кого, кого? Кіз? Ха-ха-ха».
[російською] Чотири доби ми, щоправда,
провели в машині через нашого брокера,
[російською] який забув сказати, що треба поставити
там одну печатку на одному документі.
[російською] Тому вони у нас і стали «золотими»,
[російською] бо коли ми чотири рази
перетнули кордон через цю печатку,
[російською] ми порахували витрати,
і я сказала: «Сергійку, у нас золоті кози!»
[російською] І так ми й вирішили назватися — «Золота коза».
Ми не плануємо здоровенними рости якимись.
Ми плануємо, щоб це був європейський
формат сімейної справи, яка зосереджена на своїх.
Підем козочок пасти?
Гей-гей-гей!
Мама козами займається повністю: доїть, пасе.
Брат малий допомагає пасти, буває.
А я — вже те, що кози дають далі,
з ним працюю, з молоком, роблю сир.
Продаю його, це моя відповідальність у цьому.
[російською] Тут на фундаменті ферма стояла.
[російською] Ось це все — там і там фундамент лишився.
[російською] Це все була наша ферма.
[російською] Потім вона згоріла, за чотири години.
Вся.
[російською] Не лишилось нічого,
бо ми сюди вклали все, що мали на той період.
[російською] Перше, що ми сказали після пожежі — це:
[російською] «Ми більше цим займатись не будемо».
[російською] А потім нам почали допомагати люди!
[російською] Навіть наші замовники
надали нам фінансову допомогу.
[російською] За ці гроші ми почали відбудовуватись.
[російською] Потім ми почали їздити по Україні
та викуповувати власних тварин.
[російською] В СРСР м'ясо було дуже важливе.
[російською] І в кожному колективному господарстві
мала бути отара овець обов'язково.
[російською] І кіз завжди тримали
біля цієї отари тільки для одного:
[російською] аби можна було вигодувати ягнят,
яких не прийме вівцематка.
[російською] Їх спеціально ніхто ніколи не доїв,
усе було для м'яса.
[російською] Так! Країна була не заточена на здоров'я людини.
[російською] Вона була заточена
на сильну обороноздатну армію.
[російською] Сказати, що ми раді,
що з Кримом так вийшло? Напевно, ні.
[російською] А те, що в нас зріє такий
шикарний бізнес і улюблена справа?
[російською] Напевно, так.
І наші діти живуть в чистому районі.
[російською] Нам випав такий шлях —
потрібно було його пройти.
[російською] Потрібно було все-таки...
— [російською] А в Крим хочеться! Інжир зірвати...
— [російською] Так, дуже хочеться.
[російською] У нас інжир прямо з балкону —
ми його там зривали, їли, збирали.
Аня у нас займається ще туризмом.
Вона приймає гостей, приймає групи, проводить екскурсії.
Ну, а Захар — дитячі екскурсії.
Зазвичай, коли приїжджає сім'я, він одразу бере за руку
дітей і веде до себе в пісочницю.[сміється]
На машинці до козеняток,
до козочок маленьких погладити їх, погодувати.
Показує все, розказує.
Не треба їхати кудись в Швейцарію, в Альпи,
щоб спробувати швейцарського сиру.
Можна приїхати на Тетіївщину,
і тут така сама горбиста місцевість,
такий же смачний сир — далеко їхати не треба.
Я насолоджуюсь моментом, який є.
Те, що ми робимо — реально показати,
що не обов'язково їхати в місто, щоб заробляти.
Можна заробляти і в селі.
[російською] Найголовніше — просто любити те,
чим ви займаєтесь і горіти цим.
[російською] І щоб це було в кайф,
[російською] щоб ви отримували від цього задоволення
і розуміли, що це комусь ще потрібно, крім вас.
[російською] Сім'ї купують по декілька років в нас продукцію.
[російською] І ми розуміємо,
що їм це потрібно, і нам це подобається.
[російською] І тварини нам подобаються,
нам подобається робити сири.
[російською] Нам подобається творити.
[російською] Якщо цим не горіти і якби це не подобалося,
ми не починали б це знову [після пожежі].